our next speaker is su Chitra
Ramachandran and her title for the three
minute thesis the brain as a
statistician when we were infants
learning our first languages we did not
learn it because someone sat us down and
taught us the rules of grammar no we
learned it implicitly almost by osmosis
simply because we were surrounded by
people who spoke that language indeed
studies show that when infants hear
speech
all they hear is the sequence of sounds
but over time they're able to tell that
certain sounds go together more often
than others and so they are able to
parse those outis words this implies
that we have an innate mechanism that
allows us to discover structure and
patterns and regularities in the
environment around us and we are able to
do this in an implicit unsupervised
manner this form of learning is called
statistical learning and it's something
you're eight months eight month old can
do and it's something that distinguishes
our intelligence from that of machines
what are the brain mechanisms underlying
this what algorithms with our brain used
to do this these are the kinds of
questions that I'm trying to explore for
my thesis and I'm studying this in
monkeys why monkeys because monkeys are
very closely related to us
evolutionarily they are not like us and
statistical learning has been observed
in monkeys most importantly we can
monitor the activities of single cells
called neurons in a monkey's brain well
it is awake and engage with the world
around it monkeys are highly visual
creatures so we decided to subject our
monkeys to an artificial visual
environment consisting of statistically
regular events for an entire month day
after day after day we had our monkey
stood in a chair pay the screen where
images would come on one at a time
but another the monkey the order in
which the images were displayed had a
certain regularity inbuilt into them for
example whenever the monkey saw the
image of the Starbucks male it was
always followed by the image of the
coffee cup remember that these images
meant nothing to the monkey they were
just visual stimuli no behavioral
relevance whatsoever at the end of
training we wanted to ask but they're
single neurons in a part of the brain
that processes such visual images to
tell the difference between events that
conform to the regularities in post
during training and events which
violated the regularities and force
during training we observe something
very interesting
whenever the monkey saw something that
was statistically likely something that
conformed with the regularities imposed
during training we found that the
activity of the neurons were suppressed
but when the monkey saw the same image
in a context where it was statistically
unlikely for example the folks wagon
symbol followed by the coffee cup a
visual event that the monkey had never
seen during training we found that the
activity of the same neurons for the
same image were enhanced what does this
mean we speculate the through passive
learning and statistical passive
experience in statistical learning our
sensory systems are capable of forming
mental models of the world around us and
when events in the world conform to the
model the the model that we have then
those represent something that's
predictable something that we already
know so they are represented less
strongly but when something surprising
happens like a tiger walking in through
the room that is something exciting that
is something informative potentially
although statistically unlikely so they
may be represented more strongly what is
the nature of these internet
representations how are they acquired
and maintained over a lifetime and are
they common across all sensory domains
these are highly interesting questions
and I'm trying to answer them thank you